pas besoin d'attendre longtemps on est
par deux fois mais pour apercevoir du
haut des airs les premières mines
pétrolières les sables bitumineux sont
là camions géants et machinerie lourde
en action forte le one est une petite
communauté isolée dans le nord de
l'alberta
aucune route permanent existent pour la
connexion réseau routier à part un
chemin divers accessible quelques mois
par année c'est un lieu calme paisible
où vivent notamment les cris demi qui
sue et les dénés d'athabasca deux
premières nations qui ont un attachement
profond à la terre qui les entourent une
terre toutefois qui s'est détériorée au
fil des années les autochtones et les
pêcheurs et les chasseurs sont unanimes
les rivières ne sont plus ce qu'elles
étaient la forme n'est plus aussi
abondante cavens ici à foix qui peu
moins de la nature occupe une place
capitale pour les résidents au cours des
dernières décennies ils ont vu leur
environnement leurs communautés se
transformer et tout le monde qu'on a
rencontrés ici nous a fait part de
l'enjeu qui les préoccupent grandement
l'assèchement du delta de la rivière de
la paix et athabasca nous en avons eu la
preuve sur le lac athabasca
le niveau des lacs et rivières a diminué
de façon inquiétante ces dernières
décennies
[Musique]
parmi les responsables du déclin de
l'environnement du delta selon des
études les barrages hydroélectriques et
l'industrie pétrolière
malgré cette dégradation les sables
bitumineux pourraient à nouveau prendre
de l'expansion l'entreprise canadienne
teck resources propose de développer la
plus importante et la plus
septentrionale de toutes les mines
jamais un projet pétrolier ne s'est
autant approché de for chip one et des
premières nations qui l'entourent
malgré les craintes de la communauté
le projet a reçu l'appui de 14 groupes
autochtones dont la première nation tu
peux - d'athabasca le chef harouna dème
a signé une entente avec teck resources
mais il ne se dit pas pour autant
partisans de l'industrie ça a été une
décision difficile dit il
le resort roig egypte - les cris de mes
questions ont aussi conclu une entente
avec la pétrolière
la première nation brasse déjà des
affaires avec l'industrie ericsson cours
notamment le chèvre rêve d'indépendance
financière par rapport à ottawa
si les autochtones sont pas tous
d'accord avec leur conseil de bande
il semble toutefois unanimes quand il
s'agit de leurs droits nombre d'entre
eux disent que le gouvernement ne
respecte pas les droits reconnus par le
traité numéro 8 de nani notre confiance
ébranlée
c'est donc pour ça que les autochtones
doute de l'évaluation environnementale
du projet frontières c'est de la poudre
aux yeux selon gerry adams le déni est
persuadé que le projet mini sera
approuvée de toute façon
peu importe ce que disent les promoteurs
le fragile équilibre entre écologie et
environnement s'il y en a un est
difficilement atteignable à leurs yeux
c'est donc pour eux une impression de
déjà-vu l'impression qu'une autre mine
va saboter leur cour arrière
et comme à chaque fois distille avec ou
sans leur consentement